Hello, hello, hello!
My, my, my, my!
Go ahead, you guys!
Hello, hello, hello, sorry for the longer intro.
Um, um, what, there was like a bunch of, uh, construction
noise outside, so I was waiting for it to settle down,
settle down.
But yeah!
Hi, hi, hi, hi.
Welcome in, everybody.
Welcome back to Allin' Work.
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee.
Likely story.
Oh, by the law.
But, we're here.
We're here for chapter three?
the title is of my stream yes chapter three and last time it
was uh we what we were like at some campsite that's right we
were going our wife has been kidnapped and so we're like uh
uh you're not gonna take our wife like that and so we were
going to meet with the kidnapper at the lover peak and then
we got bam not bamboozled we got ambushed and uh then we
just run through the woods a whole lot we're in the woods so
much in this game hello me too me too me too and i boo is
like you i'm gonna be honest if i don't know if alan's ever
gonna wake up and i'm here for the ride i think will right
eventually right alan wake up alan awake if you do like a
wake like you know first initial last name it's awake so
maybe he is awake how do you mean though i'm usually stuck
being a vod watcher but not today Thanks for giving me so
many streams to watch up at my breaks and lunches.
Me too cute!
Oh my gosh, Stafford, thank you!
I'm glad you can watch with us.
Ouch, I don't know why.
My nose is hurting all of a sudden.
Hold on.
It's hurting.
Not itching, it's hurting.
I just got out of Alan work.
Time for Alan Wake.
Outsu!
Outsu, Outsu, gappu!
what if he was alan woke he's been waked he's been awake for
too long he's he's he's woke up
it's the season for viruses i don't think it's that i don't
know when you're a ghost you just have random pains it's
just how it goes it's like the thing ghosty thing oh my gosh
eternal pain and suffering blah blah blah
it hurts though anyway whatever alan 21 months i don't i
don't think so i don't think that's his name a phantom bird
truly alan wick don't call him that don't call him that um
but uh kuboff thank you so much for the 21 months thank you
thank you happy to catch this live thank you thank you
Roll-Runner cartoons.
Hello, me toe, looking cute as always.
Hi, frill!
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh my gosh, my voice is from yesterday.
I didn't realize that I sung almost 30 songs.
Just kind of insane.
How Alan wake on his birthday be like, Alan cake.
Does he have any Alan cake?
We shall decide that today.
We'll give him a good look over, a good up and down and see
if this guy is deserving of the title Alan cake I don't
think so by size welcome back thank you so let's just get
into it yeah I'm excited I do have stuff that I need to do
after stream though so I'm like hmm help you folks oh my
goodness hello I'm the manager we're looking for Rose works
as a waitress down at the diner Rose sure nice girl Who
wants to know?
Me!
I'm Alan Wake.
The writer, huh?
I heard on the radio you were visiting.
Well, I'll show you her trailer.
That Rose, she's a nice girl.
Always pays her rent on time.
As I was saying, Al, I found all sorts of weird stuff from
the local newspapers' archives.
Where are you going?
This place is crazy.
Don't avoid me.
Where are you going?
Barry, don't avoid me.
most of this stuff takes place around Cauldron Lake well you
ain't wrong mister the Indians thought the lake was a
doorway to the underworld I'm the god-fearing type myself I
don't hold with that sort of thing yeah okay anyway let me
speak please there was an island there owned by a guy called
Thomas Zane now some of the articles I found about him make
him out to be a famous writer but I ran a bunch of searches
couldn't find a single thing he wrote he's a writer just
like me the place came to be called diver's aisle but the
volcano under the lake erupted in 1970 and zane went i think
we almost got buried to go full owl come on okay yes this
i'm sorry i wanted to like expect kind of go over again at
the end of uh chapter two uh we got a mysterious phone call
from rose uh she's the girl who works at the diner and she
was like like, she was like, oh yeah, come to my place.
I don't remember why.
Actually, I don't remember why, but Wake and Barry have
arrived at the trailer park to meet Rose, who says she has
Wake's manuscript.
That's what she said.
So we're at Sparkling River Estates.
Come on, mister.
I'll take you to Rose's trailer.
Okay, I'm exploring a little bit.
I'm making a mess and a ruckus.
What's this say?
recycle oh my god he hates me he hates nature she had the
manuscript dump it over dump it over knock it over listen i
got things to do this place don't run itself okay well
here's somebody like chopping wood all right let's follow
this guy anybody have any thermoses around any collectibles
can i steal from the good people of this park?
Alan's doll.
Does this one also say don't recycle?
It does.
Why do they hate nature?
This is so terrible.
It's like right in... Oh my gosh.
How are you supposed to get to your door?
You don't...
Give me a break, mister.
Can we just get a move on?
Please.
I like to explore and see my...
See where I'm at.
This is my inspiration for...
Oh my!
Did I do that?
This is the inspiration for my next novel!
Wait, did I do that?
Oh my god, I'm pushing the whole car.
That spooked me!
Holy cow.
Alan Strong.
One second.
Parkour What's this?
I hear them In the woods I don't see anybody though Alright
Watch this Barry Watch this Oh my god Wait a second Does
this not look like the exact staircase of that one meme of
the guy Who like falls down the stairs He like has the heart
attack or whatever what is that from anyway and you're like
he's like it looks exactly like that place
looks exactly like it
somebody you can have my 3d model and you could just take
the map from this place and then you could recreate recreate
me doing it well now watch this berry i'm gonna do a famous
viral meme
Ow!
On it, boss.
Okay, I look forward to it.
Oh.
Checkpoint reached.
Cool.
Very cool.
All right, I'm gonna leave you.
And I'm gonna go do my own thing again.
I just like looking around.
It's so interesting.
Spector!
Welcome to a bamboo ship.
Thank you.
Sorry if my voice is a little hoarse.
Yeah, how about that?
It was there in the morning, as if it had fallen from the
sky.
But it would take a tornado to lift something like that.
We're damn lucky it didn't crush any of the trailers.
What the heck?
A whole boat!
Why?
Is it because I stole?
I'm so sorry.
What's that sound?
Is that a vacuum?
Hello?
Someone's working?
Let me know if the volume is too loud or not later on.
It probably will be too loud.
I like how Barry just follows me anywhere.
Probably will be too loud later because I have it like all
the way up right now.
Especially when I'm shooting.
Randy's dogs.
But there's a dog right there.
Okay.
I'm following, I'm following.
Aren't those wasps?
No, I think you sound like a vacuum, yeah.
Wait, what's this?
Dogs.
Hot dog.
Chili dog.
Corn dog.
Taco dog.
A taco?
Look at these prices even.
These are Costco prices.
The famous dog.
Big dog.
Monster dog.
Belly buster.
Ew.
I thought the trailer trash dog was $82 for a second.
Special plates.
Crash, thank you so much for the 20.
Yes, thank you.
What the dog doing?
Rabbit food.
Salad.
With chicken.
What is this menu?
Small side salad, extra dressing, extra fix-ins, just ask
for.
Rabbit food.
You're okay, I'm coming, I'm coming, sorry.
She is far out here, isn't she?
Oh, are we...
This isn't trespassing, is it?
It gets better.
A local girl, Barbara Jagger, drowned in Cauldron Lake just
a week earlier.
Whoa.
Jagger's a local spook store.
The scratch and hag.
Scratch and hag!
Come for you in the dark.
Childish stuff like that.
Anyway, Al.
I'm just getting to the best part.
All of the articles about this stuff were written by Cynthia
Weaver.
Cynthia Weaver.
I asked around, and she's that crazy bad lady you met.
Oh!
What?
The lamp lady?
She can be a little loopy, but she's not homeless anymore.
Yeah.
Anyway, she knew both Jagger and Zane before they both died.
and she had some kind of a breakdown.
I like how he waited all of this time to continue the story.
Note that all the Stucky's favorite dogs he mentioned are
the largest portions.
One big Tao, please, me Tao.
Coming right up.
Where is the person that is chopping wood?
I hear them still.
What if you think it's like a speaker in the woods?
a belly burster
can I ride this you can make so much noise I love it okay
alright I'm following you I'm following you so the mystery
chopper well mister this here's Rose's trailer you mind me
asking what you want with her we're just here to talk to her
pal This doesn't seem intimidating at all.
We're just here to talk to her.
Pow.
I see a thermos in there.
Okay, I'm gonna rob Rose now.
Excuse me.
Where do you think she was hiding?
Welcome to...
To...
Oh, dear.
Mr. Wake.
I'm...
I'm so glad you're here.
Rose, you have my manuscript?
Oh.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Please come in.
This doesn't seem suspicious at all.
Oh, my God.
Don't drink it.
Hey, this is really good.
Rose.
Yes.
My manuscript.
I really need it.
I understand.
I know what you need.
Amuse to inspire you.
Oh, for Barry.
She doesn't have anything.
Yeah.
Uh, hey, Al.
How was... Oh.
Barry!
What?
Oh no.
Oh, I told you guys not to drink it.
Oh man.
Who could have thunk this would happen?
He's not Alan Wake anymore!
It's coming for you.
Hiding in my barber's skin.
Oh my gosh, so loud.
I'm too weak to stop it.
You must turn the lights on.
Turn the lights on.
I promised I'd come visit you and your lovely wife.
Helen sweet.
You must find what you started.
I insist.
You must turn the lights on.
Turn the lights on.
Turn the light on.
Ooh!
Back to work, boy.
Ah!
Is that me above her bed?
turn the lights on oh my god I can't tell reality from dream
anymore but it seems I have an imaginary editor to help me
she's an old woman in a funeral dress I call her Barbara
Jagger Barbara her name is Barbara and faster my manuscript
is being heavily revised the edits are getting very
aggressive each day there's less of me and more of her I
hate it But I know she's right.
What do you mean?
She promises me I can save Alice this way.
She knows more of this than I do.
Barba.
About the complex incantation I'm attempting.
About this place.
She's worked with another writer under similar
circumstances.
Thomas Zane.
The genre of the story seems to be shifting.
It's turning into a horror story.
I'm getting close.
I can feel it.
Ooh.
Spooky.
The tone is shifting.
Oh my goodness.
look at the shades on oh wow she has so many of my books and
she has other books not a real fan am i her oshi or what
this is crazy i guess i mean this feels like this feels like
like a like a 12 year old putting justin beaver on top of
her like a you know What is that?
Who's that guy?
Believe in change.
Alan Oshie.
Rose took a day from me.
I had less than 12 hours left to meet the kidnapper.
All I could do was get Barry into the car, work something
out once I got on the road.
Thank you.
Barry!
Barry was out of it.
He was way too heavy to carry.
Oh, I thought we were supposed to get him in the car.
uh-oh you're right i deserve more money i'm so handsome uh
rose welcome to the oh dear diner oh geez what can i get you
today coffee i couldn't work up much hate for rose something
had used her to get to me and left its mark oh is she gonna
be okay oh she's got little pictures when you like to hear
today's specials thank you I think I would hate this setup,
though.
It looks like a restaurant booth in my home.
I don't know about that.
She got a little island and everything, though.
It's pretty fancy.
All right, hold on.
Okay, it's not letting me do anything with guns yet, so I
think no combat yet.
Okay.
My gun and flashlight were gone.
I'd have to find a way to get Barry into the car as quickly
as possible.
There was no time to waste.
Okay.
What's this?
My manuscript.
Let's see what we got here.
Ransom!
Nice Aibu Taku Collection, Rose.
Randolph calls the police.
Mr. Randolph like Rose.
That little smile she had.
How she was still sweet when life had tried so hard to make
her bitter.
It wasn't any of this business what she did in her trailer.
strangers the writer and his smart ass sidekick looked like
trouble and they've been in there for hours way past her
normal bedtime he reached for the phone and called the
sheriff's station oh no uh oh wait no no you don't
understand we're the victims here wait wait wait please
understand we are the ones who uh wait this is so bad um
okay so we can't go that way we have to get to the car Can't
go that way because of the boat that mysteriously landed.
Oh, what's this?
I just stepped outside to catch a breath of fresh air.
Let me tell you.
I keep adjusting the volume because the...
Nights like this make me especially glad I'm here talking to
you and not home in bed.
Once the weather takes a turn like this, I can't sleep at
all.
So how does he know we're bedtime?
Dead sheets and dark thoughts.
punctuated by the occasional plunge into nightmare is it
just me well perhaps it is the volume's all right on our end
i hope i can make the night a little bit easier it's either
too quiet or too loud yeah hey hey it's waltz yeah i'll wait
until this is on your mind waltz well you
can't sleep i can't sleep or either i've been staring out of
the window here trying to make sense of it all but what's
going on i've been thinking either you know i just a man
with a problem waltz yeah yeah uh
argument with danny you know danny and oh no you know and um
i'm just my bad waltz yeah well you know he's uh you know
daddy's my best friend and uh yeah yeah and now i'm just
alone here at the window you know waiting man there's
something in the air tonight man man what's going on man oh
yeah what are you waiting for it's quite foggy i don't know
you know something's gonna have
to get better go is this the guy that was in jail maybe
right thanks pat well good luck to you walt hey
okay all right i'm going to let's see if i can fix this a
little bit what we'll do is i'll do like this maybe if it's
overkill i can change it obviously but i feel like speech is
gonna be you know it's been the lowest thing okay oh yeah
okay um the car is down here to the right Are we gonna have
to fight Randolph?
Is he gonna go crazy evil?
Oh, there he is.
Um, excuse me.
Excuse me, I need to leave.
Oh, you're gonna get it now.
Ah!
Wait!
God knows what you've done to that poor girl.
This is Agent Nightingale, FBI.
Get him up, Hemingway.
You're under arrest.
What did I do?
You have a muscle all unload right in your goddamn face.
Stay right where you are, Triple H.
Oh my god, wait, wait, why are we shooting?
Oh my god, you're gonna kill that guy.
Oh my god!
Oh, are we back in the woods?
No, why?
I'm standing right here, you goddamn maniac.
No.
I hated to leave Barry behind, but there was no way I'd miss
my opponent.
Escape the police?
Oh my god, wait.
How do I...
I gotta go this way.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm in...
What grounds do you have to arrest me, huh?
Wee-woo, wee-woo.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, that doesn't seem good.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
For acting, suss.
No!
You don't see me?
Not the flare.
Oh my god.
Am I supposed to be stealthy here?
I can't tell at all.
Wake!
That's me.
Just gonna keep Roddick.
He needs an Allen break.
Yeah, for me.
wait uh go up go up go up go up yeah go go go this way i
think all right just follow the road manuscript page okay
we're we're on the right way why are the police after me
come on guys we need to head him off no hold on i need to
read for a second pick up pick up Need to read.
The dark presence sleeps.
For decades, the darkness that wore Barbara Jagger's skin
slept thickly in the dark place that was its home and
prison.
It was hungry and in pain.
It dreamed of its nights of glory when the poet's writing
had called it from the depths and given it a brief, terrible
taste of power and freedom.
The rock stars had stirred it from the deep sleep the poet
had sunk it back to in the end.
When it sensed the writer on the ferry, it opened its eyes.
It dreamed of its nights of glory when the poet's writing
had called it from the depths and given it a brief terrible
taste of power and freedom.
Was the, why is the darkness so obsessed with books?
Work has been super busy, but I'm trying to catch up on
VODs.
Falling, thank you, Brother Pink.
Super excited for February.
I can't be there in person, so I'm gonna buy a stream ticket
and merch for sure.
Thank you!
Hope you have a good day.
You too!
You too, you too.
Thank you so much.
What?
Okay, back to running.
Is the darkness still sleeping?
The weather's getting bad.
Oh shoot.
That's not my fault.
Checkpoint reached.
Catch your breath, Alan.
I'm gonna go back and investigate what's going on over here.
Oh, what are they saying?
Over.
He's a loose cannon, he is.
Out.
Oh, damn.
Wait, there is something over here.
I'm glad I checked.
Manuscript.
Almost missed it.
More reading.
Rose visited by the dark prince.
Rose didn't know how the strange old lady got in her trailer
and she looked wrong somehow.
Hi Mito, hello!
The woman showed her teeth in an approximation of a smile
and traced a finger down Rose's cheek.
Pretty girl.
Her cheek pretty girl.
But her knees didn't buckle.
The crone spoke in a whisper.
Her words ice cold and dark in Rose's ear.
Ew!
Nasty.
Go away, old lady.
All right.
Crone.
That didn't sound very sturdy.
Push it over.
Yeah.
Alan Destroy.
Alan Hulk.
All right.
Let's keep escaping.
Question mark?
We are escaping.
The police, maybe.
What was that?
Oh, a flare.
Where are we even running to?
We don't even know.
We're just running.
Stay sharp.
Don't look at me.
Don't look up.
Gamers don't look up.
No.
Maybe I should go to.
Oh!
I'll go around it.
That didn't seem good.
This horror was everywhere I went.
Circling me.
This is...
The cops didn't stand a chance.
Killing a lot of people, huh?
They were after a rider.
Not a monster.
No!
My lamp!
Please!
Yeah, we're like kind of really bad for this place now.
Over.
She called me a geek.
Oh.
We're escaping the police still?
We're doing it?
Softendo, thank you so much for the redirect!
Hello, hello!
Checkpoint reached, baby.
Is that a helicopter?
Can't be that long.
Hello?
It's coming from that the way.
Raymag, thank you so much for the captain!
Oh.
Oh, shoot!
It didn't seem, man.
Fine.
Oh my god.
Wait, what is that?
The birds are after him!
Wait, how did that happen?
The birds!
They're spitting seeds or something.
Oh my god!
Man down, man down!
Okay, so there's an open door here, but obviously I want to
go up.
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
Ducky, thank you so much for the...
For the gifted!
Uh, zoom?
Oh my god.
Oh, it's sensitive.
Is that the gas station we were at before that we, like,
made our way to?
Uh, a while ago?
First chapter?
Maybe different gas station?
Can't imagine there's so many...
No way!
Thermus!
It seems like it?
Oh wow!
We're back.
Wow.
Okay.
Thermos.
Is this a fire...
Firewatch place?
Thermos.
Getting your place all dirty.
Nasty.
Doesn't look very lived in at all.
Oh, this is Jane.
Bulligan Thornton come in!
Over!
Uh, Thornton here?
Uh, Gates.
We got both Wheeler and Rose in custody.
Rose!
Why did they
arrest Rose?
We got Wheeler and Rose here.
Is his name Barry Wheeler?
Boy.
Ooh.
Bamboo, thank you so much.
Welcome back.
Uh, I don't have anything on that day.
Thank you so much!
Okay.
Anyway, Rose.
Rose is just being plain weird here.
You better get docked in to take a look at both of us.
Oh.
Gotcha.
You better get them here quickly.
The Fed's gonna want to interview the wheeler over.
Oh, geez.
Oh, yeah, I bet.
Oh, look at that.
They're holding my people.
Well, not so much Rose, but, you know.
Let's see.
What do we have over here?
What do we...
Oh.
Radio tower.
And what's this?
the radio station in the distance yeah i guess that's where
we're headed barry we gotta save that guy oh you're fine
you're fine everything's cool we're chill is there anything
else over here okay here we go through here what's this away
i imagine that the broadcast tower in the distance was part
of the local radio station.
Main seemed like a decent guy.
Perhaps he could give me directions to the coal mine.
Oh, okay.
I thought that this way was a way.
But it doesn't seem like it.
What's that light down there?
If I drop, do I die?
Oh, you won't let me.
Yes?
You guys were all wrong.
They wouldn't even let me drop.
I would have been done with this.
Oh,
the crows.
Oh!
Unnatural shadows clung to the gate.
The darkness that was after me was trying to stop me.
I wouldn't get through without a light.
Destroy the gate.
Look at it.
It's shivering.
So cold.
Why are you moving like that?
Little jerky.
all right let's go find the light i suppose the fire watch
wouldn't they will most definitely have a flash flash flash
light sorry no right
you would think so i'm gonna double check one more time can
i borrow this lamp anything in the stove Nothing.
A whole lot of nothing.
All right, hold on.
Can you see it from here?
It'd be so funny.
No.
Oh, yes you can!
We see you shaking behind the tree.
Um...
Man, I think we need maybe fire.
Fire.
Maybe.
Hi, hi Minto!
Hello!
Hello, Brandon!
Hoi hoi.
Oh, can we jump here?
Oh!
Oh no!
We're still escaping the police!
Wait, do I have to do this again?
I thought we hit a checkpoint before, my bad.
Listen to this again?
Yeah, sorry, my bad guys.
My curiosity.
Okay, we're gonna do multiple...
Alright.
Whoa, what the heck just happened?
Wait, one second?
Sorry.
Uh...
What just happened?
Oh, what is this?
What the heck is this?
Wait.
Oh, sorry.
Something like some weird pop-up showed up on my computer.
Weird!
Okay, we're good.
I could see the lights at the radio station in the distance.
Yeah.
Darkness virus.
It actually, like, yeah, it's kind of weird.
I think it might be the interface for, what's it called, the
Epic Store or whatever the heck?
Glitching a little.
I imagine that the broadcast tower in the distance was part
of the local radio station.
station main seemed like a decent guy perhaps he could give
me directions to the coal mine okay and then the freaky wind
a natural shadow is clung to the gate the darkness that was
oh my gosh that hurt bad okay sorry geez oh everything up
here that bit me literally bit me is this it doesn't seem
like it can even I was gonna say does it need to be powered
but it doesn't look like it can be let's see what we got
over here we got this bad boy with a blinking light we got a
sick ramp whoa and we got there was no power to the search
light Oh.
Really?
Not?
It is this thing?
This thing looks a million years old.
You've got the right idea.
Oh, I see a button there.
Oh.
A sick ram.
I don't think this thing should be working.
Oh my god.
The sparks coming out of it.
it this is this this seems scary this seems like the
equivalent of oh ellie the old generator conked out i'd have
to see if i could fix it and try again oh my god really but
this seems like the equivalent of like putting a blow dryer
a hair dryer in uh in a bathtub
You awake?
I'm working on it.
Alright, let's do this again.
Oh!
Just kidding.
I don't need to do... Wait, it just dissolved.
The whole thing dissolved.
Can I turn it back on?
No!
Okay.
Gate defeated.
The real boss of Alan Wake.
Gates and boundaries.
Alright, checkpoint reached.
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just gotta go towards the light.
La, la, la, towards the light.
The one time I'll...
Oh my god, another gate.
The one time I should be going towards the...
Wait, what's that?
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
Wait, we don't have baddies, do we?
Because I still don't have a gun.
But I have a flashlight.
Which is great.
And five batteries.
Nice.
And...
Yeah.
Those darn gates.
One bad thing.
I know I choose to play like the games once a week.
Because part of me...
What is happening here?
Part of me likes to have it kind of seem like a weekly
episodic episode for these types of games.
But then the...
It took me a moment to recognize the flashbang grenades.
They were an ideal weapon for my situation.
Nice.
The terrible thing is I forget how to play.
You show those gates for a minute.
Yeah.
I will.
Flashbang!
Nice.
You trying to talk to me?
Holy cow.
I could never play games just once a week like this.
It's difficult for me too.
I do it for like a couple reasons.
One is because, you know, if someone...
can't catch the vod i like to give them the opportunity to
to watch it like it gives you a week to catch up if you're
like for especially for episodic story or like you know uh
not episodic but well i guess not really well you know like
story heavy story heavy games like this
i totally get it but there's always trade-offs exactly
exactly so
so our way to throw the flash oh my god no oh shoot wait
wait but i don't have a gun for you oh shoot i don't have a
thing to kill you with oh my god come here okay oh shoot
oh man i don't have a gun i have to rely on bombs?
This sucks.
This sucks, this sucks, this sucks, this sucks.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Fine.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Oh,
no, I'm gonna run out.
I need to go that away.
This away.
Yeah, shut up.
Oh, more flashbacks, more flashbacks.
More flashbacks.
Hello?
And here's another call.
You're on KBFFM with...
KBFFM?
It's Milp Peabody, Pat.
What's on your mind, Milp?
Well, I live near the trailer park, Pat, and there's a big
ruckus going on over there.
Well, that's just up the road for me, too.
you know I don't know but there's a bunch of police cars
there lots of sirens helicopters for one man mind you
they're doing all this for one guy a pistol because it's
just next door and they're popping off guns there they're
still shooting no it was maybe 10 15 minutes ago uh-oh
sounds serious Pat I'm
I'm certainly going to give the station a call, Milt.
Okay.
You'll hear it here.
Who's sure does that?
Okay, thanks.
Yeah, give the station a call.
The music is so funny.
He's like, there's a lot of stuff going on.
What's up here?
Anything?
It looks like a pathway, though.
Am I crazy?
Gosh, this game...
This game feels way too open world.
Alright, I got six.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, manuscript.
Another guy.
Oh my god, wait, a bunch of guys.
Holy cow.
Come here.
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Kill him!
Yeah.
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
Get back to the light.
Wait, is the light out?
Oh, the light.
No, the light is out.
Why?
But we only use two.
Which seems to be the ideal.
Oh, let's check it out.
Pat is playing killer frequency while you are running
around.
in the woods it's true if you don't know what the game
killer frequency is it's a game that's like takes place all
in a radio station about like a real killer on the loose
everything was drawn in black and gray crayons the old lady
had promised her that all her wishes would come true she
would be alan wake's muse oh she was smiling so hard it hurt
her face she crushed a bottle full of sleeping pills into
the coffee deep down inside she was screaming in terror.
Oh, no.
No, Rose!
Who would win in a fight, Casper?
Are you?
Always mean.
Doesn't matter who I'm up against.
Always mean, though.
Always bet on mean, though.
I guess I forget that in these fights I can also use my
flashlight to, like, You know, stun them.
Oh shoot!
Oh!
I only have three left though.
Not good.
What's this away?
Oh, my bad.
It's not vitamin spray.
Minit sprays.
Secret.
What's this?
Oh!
Please!
Give me some light!
What's this say?
Trust no one in the dark.
Where's the light?
Let there be a lot.
Three flares.
Flare gun!
Ammo.
Batteries.
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah.
Light.
What's this say?
Walk in light.
Yeah, I would if I could, you know.
That seems really awesome if that were.
If I could do that all the time.
The flash bombs, though, have been kind of awesome.
Been really appreciating flash banging everybody.
I mean, do you hear this?
Oh, the cops.
Where did I come from?
Oh, shoot.
I should have gotten them, maybe.
I think?
I think so?
To the cops?
Hello?
You went flying.
Oh, flashbang.
Yeah, take them.
Take them all.
Scaring me.
Found the cops.
Cops mean ammo.
This flashlight is terrible.
Why is it so narrow.
Oh, shoot.
I didn't mean to do that.
I didn't mean to do it.
I should have just run, maybe.
Ammo equals enemies.
I know, it's the worst trade-off ever.
Wait, the music stopped.
Eepie!
Oh.
Never mind.
It's still bad.
It's got to be more than one, right?
Oh.
I wasted it for just one guy.
I got one guide for real?
No!
Yeah, check it out.
I hope Maine could lend me a car to get to the coal mine.
Oh, he's in there!
Maine!
Let me take your thermos first.
It's a trailer bar.
Whoa, they did my...
They did him so dirty.
This is like...
What's his vision like?
Like minus eight?
What is this?
He's cute though.
It's so funny.
Take it.
I'm looking around.
Is this a dumpster's full of ammo?
Anything around?
What is...
Is this supposed to be electrocuted?
Or electrified?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's hardcore for a radio station.
Minus 8, minus 20.
Yeah, for real.
I'm trying to see what his license plate is.
Does that actually...
It looks like Fujisan.
Is that actually what the Washington plates look like,
though?
Keep out wildlife.
Oh, you know what?
That makes the most sense.
More than, like, keeping out...
You know, trespassers.
This picture, though.
I think it's supposed to be lighting.
That's what it's supposed to be.
Yo, it's so funny looking.
Dang.
Wait, shh, don't say that.
I'm going to see if I can talk him into an interview.
Wait, shh, shh, shh.
Don't tell everybody that I'm here.
Come on in, Mr. Wake.
Okay.
Now police are going to be here in 0.2 seconds.
It looks like Mr. Wake is going to need a moment before...
Oh, I'm so glad you could find the time to do this, Mr.
Wake.
Oh, there's the cops.
I told you.
Nowhere to run down, Jay.
well well everyone come on cool could that be cool your jets
night and gal we got him what the hell's the matter with you
there's a civilian in there
dan brown's the writer of the da vinci code oh okay
oh my i'll get you yet even if it kills me you hear me you
hear me hb love craft i had fallen off cliffs it was
ridiculous that's what you get for naming a book the sudden
stop it was probably good I hadn't had the chance to tell
Maine where I was going I'd have to lose the cops and find
my own way to the mine I was in there for two seconds man oh
my gosh this guy is crazy I'll get you and your little pet
yet my dearie what's with this guy manuscript Oh, look at
that!
We can actually see the train going by!
That's so cool!
Wow.
Yep.
He's FBI's top guy.
I believe him.
I believe you.
Nightingale in the radio station.
Nightingale stared through the broken studio window into the
dark woods.
He turned around, started to walk out, but Maine grabbed his
arm.
you almost shot me you don't shoot off rounds at people like
that what's the matter with you nightingale shook his arm
free marched out his cheeks burned with rage and humiliation
i think this is like a lupon what's his name zenigata or
something i think this is one of those kinds of situations
um and i'm feeling it oh yeah more flares more flares yeah
this is for my gun right Wait.
Oh, I can... Oh, just kidding.
Okay.
Interesting.
So once I run out of the flashbangs...
Wait, what's that... There's something shining over there.
Zenigata is at least halfway competent.
Uh-oh.
We're back into the Spooky.
Everything is terrible.
A lot of
ammo.
That's scary.
I don't like that.
Stop!
Okay, we're fine.
Revolver!
Oh my god, we have a gun!
We have a gun again!
Oh no, we have a gun again.
All that for two bozos?
Look, I didn't have a choice.
I thought I saw something shining.
Oh, it was that.
It was my own flashlight.
Um, was there something over here?
Oh, yes.
Some flares.
Oh, come on!
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
Ow!
Please!
Oh, my God, I'm trying to change this.
My bad.
There we go.
Oh, if I...
If I'm going out, you're all good.
going out with me.
I have to remember.
No way.
Yeah.
Taking you out with me.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, hold that.
Where's the other guy at?
No, really.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much for the 20k so thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Where's the other guy?
There was two of them, no?
I'm not going to complain.
We keep going.
We'll save our flashbang for the big boys.
What is up there, though?
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, there's three of them.
Oh, shoot.
You shall not pass.
Oh!
Are you trying to...
Are you trying to get me?
No!
Oh shoot.
Oh, I did not mean to do that, but that's okay.
Oh my god, they're tough.
Tough guys!
Holy...
I'm doing it!
Thank you so much for that, Captain!
What is up here though?
I'm gonna check it out.
It's the opposite way of where I need to go, but I'm so
fascinated.
This is definitely...
Look!
Oh my god, he's coming after me!
Holy hell!
Whoop!
Juke's like crazy.
Oh shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, you're dead.
You're not dead!
Oh, you're not dead!
Oh my god!
What the hell?
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm
running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm ready,
I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm
ready, I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready,
I made an executive decision.
I changed my mind.
See, there were two of them!
Where's the other guy though?
Did he get... got by the light?
Does he like...
Huh.
Red barrel exploded.
I don't know.
Whatever.
We're just gonna keep going.
Hold on.
Let's put these on.
I think Bro got cooked by the lamp.
That's craziness.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here.
Come here!
Woo!
Is he down?
He was down, right?
Oh.
Maybe not.
I think I hear someone behind me!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god!
I thought he was...
Is he still?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, please!
Holy cow!
Okay, let's just... I'm gonna wait for my flashlight to
regenerate.
Then we're gonna keep going, and I'm gonna reload.
I can't... Oh, I have four bullets left, oh my gosh.
Okay, just kidding.
No!
Stay away from me.
You're free.
There was no sensible reason for the power company work
lights to be here.
Oh, ouch.
It was almost as hard for my life for someone like me to
use.
What'd you say?
Sorry, I'm fighting for my literal life right now, okay?
Please.
What did you say?
What is this?
Oh, the revolver.
Oh, let's go.
No, please!
Don't do that!
He's wondering why the power company is leaving out
flashbangs.
Oh!
Yeah, good question.
Six shots.
And then it helps me go to the next location.
Checkpoint.
Now they're facing each other.
It's dark cross lovers.
That's this way.
Don't fall.
They're pretty good.
Thank you!
Okay, they're going out.
What's in here though?
Oh, big gun!
Shotgun.
Oh!
holy wait that's a lot of them oh shoot um there's a lot of
guys here oh my god oh shoot holy shit i think
i need health i think i need health if i turn this on
Does that heal me?
Make me heal faster?
How did I live?
I don't know.
I'm sweating so much.
This game makes me sweat so much.
Turned them on when the guys are around.
Yeah, but I like got ambushed inside a building.
It was kind of difficult to leave.
Wait, what's this say?
The darkness controls the taken.
Thank you.
going this way is there anything else around here this place
is scary it's like so scary and not like i feel like i'm
gonna you know in light you can hurt them yeah oh there's
more stuff oh uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh
uh-oh uh-oh
Up on the roof?
How do you even?
Oh, I see!
Wait, how do you get up there?
But what is up there?
What is up?
Oh, come on, Alan.
I need you to work with me here.
I need you to apply yourself a little bit, please.
Oh, don't do that.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, no, no, don't slide.
Oh, my gosh.
Alright, Alan.
Alan, balance.
Yeah.
Is there anything even up here?
No riding.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice and easy.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm up here.
What now?
Oh, yeah.
We made it!
Alan.
Oh.
Now what?
We get a nice view of the...
of the area?
What?
I guess it's just for, like, storytelling to show why
there's a hole in the roof.
But I feel like there should really be...
A reason to come up here.
how mysterious for scouting maybe maybe all right hold on I
got my how many flashbittings do I have now none cool all
right love that for us
at least this way seems light seems bright
thermos and nothing else This area seems like it has a nice
bright light going on.
Just gonna keep heading there.
This is the only game seriously where I'm like, head towards
the light.
I'm gonna take a little breeding break.
Alan Yoink.
Sarah distrust Nightingale.
Sarah trusted her gut, and her gut said Agent Nightingale
was an asshole.
He felt wrong, and it wasn't just the smell of stale booze.
it was in the way he flashed his badge pulled rank the look
in his eyes when he wanted answers where was alan wake what
was this about an accident where was his wife and most
importantly why did she let wake go he wouldn't answer her
questions federal business was all he'd say
time to nerd it up with text
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, let's go.
All right.
So, we're just going to follow the tracks.
Doesn't seem very wise.
I guess it's all we got, huh?
The train!
Hello?
The most stubborn man I've ever met.
Alice?
Alan,
eyes?
Hello?
Alice!
Alice, I'm here!
Go
to hell.
You need to be careful to cooperate.
This is the...
The connection had been terrible, but that wasn't the only
thing that hadn't been right with the call.
She sounded wrong somehow.
But she had called me.
That was a modern day ransom message.
That was somebody...
That was...
You know how like people will cut up the newspapers and make
a thing like that?
That was literally...
That was just that.
Oh, okay.
I thought there was much more happening, but there wasn't.
Yeah, definitely AI generated.
Wake attacked by a possessed object?
The pipe wrenched itself loose from the bridge's steel
framework.
Wrapped in darkness, it floated in midair, twitching.
I'm sorry?
For a moment, I didn't understand what I was looking at.
Oh, boy.
The heavy object lurched at me with impossible force.
out of the way but just barely when i turned my flashlight
on it it shook in a dark rage before it flew at me again oh
is the boss this time gonna be a pipe steel pipe got mp3
come on
i could see a railway bridge up ahead yep and a warehouse of
some sort on the opposite shore yep i hoped i could find a
car from there yep all right let's not get attacked by a
pipe now okay Alan pipe Alan plump or we're taking up a new
plumbing job
uh-huh is it one of those down there oh my goodness if so
wild stuff oh why is that moving is it you You.
Is it you?
That was, that's not steel though down there.
That looks like concrete, right?
Oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
All right, this is steel.
Just a barrel.
Right.
The darkness that was pursuing me was growing strong.
Oh my god.
I was taking over everything in its path.
Oh, no, not the wood!
Oh, my gosh.
This is really getting crazy, isn't it?
What's happening?
Oh, my God.
Here it comes.
Oh, there it is.
Woo!
Oh!
Oh, my God.
You.
Oh, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Holy...
Oh, my God.
We're about to die, for real.
Oh, my God!
Okay.
We didn't get a loading.
No!
I hoped I could find a car from there.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Holy shit.
Good thing I have 17 batteries, but...
Oh, whoops.
It's flat.
Who's breathing here?
What does it say?
Follow?
follow
follow which way
do you think flares work here too oh true true have we just
it's not the um it's not like a shooting it's like you just
kind of get rid of it you banish the darkness until
until um it disappears
I do not have any flashbangs, unfortunately.
I can't tell what this is asking me to do.
Follow.
I mean, this is just part of the game, though.
Like, this is where I'm supposed to go.
Huh.
Fill their dark souls with a line.
This is weird.
Maybe something further down the bridge.
Maybe.
Mysterious.
I like how this is scripted to move.
So strange.
I don't know, sorry.
You have no reason to apologize.
Just...
The darkness that was pursuing me was growing strong.
and it was taking over Yeah, I'll try using...
Oh, no!
The void is followed on me!
Okay, this is like craziness here.
This is like really craziness here.
Stop aiming at that!
Yeah!
Oh, that worked really well.
Oh my gosh!
Out!
Oh, shoot.
I didn't mean to do that, but that's okay.
Oh.
Anything else?
That one.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
We got him.
Okay.
Sheesh!
Oh my gosh.
Let's see if there's anything over here with a yellow paint.
Nothing.
So interesting.
Why was that supposed to be a secret?
I'm gonna switch back to...
Oh my god, no way.
Again?
Is self-quit?
It's so funny.
We'd love to see it.
I wonder if there's like something over here.
Maybe I'm just psyching myself out trying to find this dang
secret.
Okay, whatever.
Why am I doing nothing?
Easiest fight of my life.
I thought I heard something coming alive here.
What do we got going on?
What are we writing about?
Wake in the dark presence in the lodge.
I slammed the door shut right in his smug face.
He pleaded for me to open the door.
True to form, the asshole actually thought I would obey.
Oh.
I had no sympathy left.
No guilt either.
Not for him.
I took a moment to savor the scream.
Oh, dang!
I bet I had a smile on my face.
It was all that I had time for.
The dark presence was inside the lodge with me.
Ooh, uh-uh.
So I'm guessing that's about Mr. Nightingale.
Rip erroneous.
As a teenager, just started to get interested in writing.
Stephen King had been a source of inspiration to me.
No kidding.
I thought about all the inanimate objects that had come to
life in his books.
No one is safe in a good horror story.
Certainly not the protagonist.
That's what makes them fun.
this was anything but the darkness could possess anything
and it was getting closer heavy-duty flashlight oh hold down
does this run out faster revolver batteries
see if there's anything else around
oh the bots is usually saved he does have a point, though,
yeah.
Oh, what's going on in here?
It doesn't seem like our flashlight changed, literally, at
all, but whatever.
Again, we do need to go out through here.
It'll close the circles faster.
Okay, that's all I needed to do, baby.
Thermos?
What is this?
What are these sounds?
I said I wasn't going to be obsessed with picking these up.
but I kind of am.
Wait, this place is in operation.
Thank you very much.
What's this?
A flare?
A singular flare?
I mean, I'll take it.
I will take it.
Look at... I'm noticing a bunch of red barrels, too.
So I'm like, what kind of fight is going to be happening
here?
This game is oddly generous, you think?
Well, I don't disagree, for sure.
But at the same time, I'm like...
It's a lot of combat.
Train fight.
Oh my god, the darkness is gold.
We'll possess the train.
Ah, here they are.
He's just... He's just standing here.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Yeah, you're gonna come here!
Oh,
I'm down.
Dang it.
Certainly not the protagonist.
That's what makes them fun.
This was anything but...
Shut up.
The darkness could possess anything, and it was getting
closer.
Uh, heavy duty.
Okay.
All right.
Yikes.
Okay.
Uh, was there anything else?
Okay, we got this.
Hmm.
I wish there was a checkpoint, like, right there.
Alan, yep.
Um.
Now, hitting that guy, did this right there.
Did do a good bit, so we'll keep that for sure.
I gotta get another one, though.
Like, maybe that one right there for the big guy or
something.
I like we just stand here in silence and they start walking
out in silence all right okay so that yeah a big guy needs a
big boom all right we gotta go boom boom hopefully I feel
like I shouldn't be playing this game with a controller but
I'm so used to playing games like this the controller now oh
whatever okay here we go oh okay there we go uh uh can i
like aim please can i please aim oh my god alan please alan
oh my god i'm gonna just shoot this one oh nope oh uh oh run
oh my god he's right behind me he's right
now i can get him get your Okay,
I got him.
Dang it.
I didn't get to...
I thought I wanted to use this one here, but...
Oh, well.
It's fine.
The dodges.
The juke's.
The maneuvers.
I go in there.
Oh, we just got the checkpoint.
Awesome.
Push it.
Alan, push.
Alan's pretty good.
Don't give him that credit.
What the?
Oh my god!
Holy cow.
It was like the softest.
He pushed over the boxes so softly.
I couldn't tell.
Like what was...
I was like, is this supposed to happen?
Everything was so soft.
What's this?
In light, you can hurt them.
I think...
I know.
I think I got that.
Thank you.
The most unsurprising knockover.
It was, like, entirely quiet.
Which is why it was just, like, was happening.
Do not recycle.
Why do these people have against recycling?
Pick up the flares.
More batteries.
More everything.
Is this TV not gonna turn on?
Oh, wait, do we get to watch the zone?
I'm in the zone.
We'll take the facts of our existence for granted.
Unaware that they're merely a thin veneer of desperate
self-delusion.
Yes.
Night Springs!
Yeah, we're in the zone.
All too often, the stars are right.
Night Springs!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
While this is happening, I'm gonna eat.
The cough drop.
The journalist Alvin Dirlis' trip to study the local customs
of an insular community in Night Springs has been less than
successful.
Until tonight.
Well, I'm glad you changed your minds about this.
Ancient customs, local mythology.
My editor loves this kind of stuff.
DERLIS.
But you have demonstrated the seriousness of your intent.
Oh, I am serious.
Really?
Just do your thing.
I'll stay out of your way and observe.
Actually, I thought you could assist us.
I'm afraid we are a man short.
It would provide you with an intimate perspective.
Could I really?
Of course, Mr. DERLIS.
DERLIS?
I guess that's the least I...
What would I have to do?
Oh, here.
Let me show you with a kiss.
I am...
What's going on?
Oh my god.
Mmm.
It's the perfect oblivious show right now.
You have well pleased Nixie Perka, the dweller in flesh.
Your body shall host his thousand young and all shall be
glory.
Oh my gosh.
Shh, darling.
Be calm.
Shh.
Wow.
Alvin Durlitz learned a harsh lesson.
If you go looking for mythology, it may come looking for
you.
That's quite the lesson.
And such quests always bear fruit.
In Night Springs.
Never kiss anybody in Night Springs, apparently.
Not the Thousand Young.
I know, it could be the Thousand Old.
It'd be so bad.
And then this wasn't on, right?
No, okay.
Okay, we're following the train track.
Oh, Manage Grampage.
Jokes on you, I've never kissed anyone.
You kissed your dog or your cat.
Those are the best kisses.
Wake attacked by the dark presence.
The darkness surged towards me, sucking everything loose
from the ground into it.
steps tugging at my clothes oh my god i saw the flare the
kidnapper had dropped and threw myself towards it just as i
felt my feet lead the ground the darkness embraced me with
the force of a tornado wow somehow i managed to light the
flare yeah the darkness roared and cast me away i fell
toward the dark waters of the lake far below what's going on
when do we get this is all at the lodge right or something
bash the pull pull part door thank you so much for the thank
you How many more pages we got?
Oh, wow!
A lot!
Okay.
What if I do this?
What if I jump here?
Jump out?
No, come on.
I can make it.
I could... I could... Wait.
I'm trying to jump across the...
the... the... the fence.
Ouch!
Okay, for it's supposedly like really dark outside, it's
quite bright.
I don't know about what you guys...
Ow, that really hurt.
Oh, we got the checkpoint, okay.
Nice.
Good, because I might die here.
It's so... there's so much happening.
Oh, okay.
Find a vehicle?
Ah!
Oh my god!
What do you mean find a vehicle?
Ah!
Oh my god.
I'm kidding.
Oh, they just ran them over.
Wait, that's kind of awesome.
Oh!
Vehicle!
Okay, I dodged that one.
I'm not gonna make this, I don't think.
That's okay, though.
Oh my gosh.
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
The vehicle found us.
I think we have to run over there and press that button.
And hope and pray that we can get to the car or something.
I think...
That's what we gotta do.
Okay, here we go.
Any flares?
I do have two, yes.
Okay, what sucks is I can't run while I have this.
So, uh...
Use.
Ouch!
Use!
Oh my god.
We're so dead.
Is that not...
Okay, that's not what we're supposed to do then.
Okay, just kidding.
Oh my god.
Who's driving this thing?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I dodged though!
I dodged that one!
It's opening!
It is?
Was it opening very slowly?
I don't know about...
Wait, what just happened?
Oh, the game is...
Okay, there we go.
Visual glitch?
It was opening slowly.
I don't think the darkness has a license.
They are not.
That's not a forklift, but they are definitely not certified
for whatever vehicle that is.
Okay.
Next time, Zag instead of Zig.
All right.
This is a Tuffy.
What else do I have?
Shotgun might be better.
This one's nutty.
Jump over the fence!
I tried!
Okay.
I just need it.
We just gotta keep trying and keep trying.
Oh my god, it's coming right at us.
Holy shit.
Nice.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I can stop it with, like, my light, though.
Or something.
Wait, did I get that other guy?
Is he down?
Oh, shoot.
He is.
Okay.
All right.
No, he's not.
Okay.
There were some batteries over here.
Oh, my gosh.
Four-point turn.
You got this?
opening.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Yes, I did it.
Oh, that wasn't so bad.
Oh, wait, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go.
That wasn't so bad.
I guess it's not a problem anymore.
I have never been this collab to see the sunrise.
I had a couple of hours to to the coal mine we just casually
wait there was so much stuff there i missed it all wait
there was so much stuff the coal mine wasn't far now
oh go to the coal mine today i would meet the kidnapper and
he would give me alice i wouldn't give him any other choice
a drowning man will clutch at a straw
That is true.
What if I go this way?
How far will the game let me run?
Okay, no.
Sorry.
A win's a win.
Dang it.
I feel like I missed so much stuff, though.
Where are we, anyway?
Good morning, Minto.
Welcome to Bright Falls.
Coal Mine Museum.
I am.
Yeah.
Don't sweat it?
There were like at least two, what's it called?
Like red boxes of supplies that I missed, but not that I can
use it now anyway.
Don't do it.
Don't do it, Alan.
This game is really pretty though.
Wow.
Do it.
Drive the car, can we?
Am I taking the slow, scenic way?
Oh!
On the road again.
Little by little, without realizing it, I'd come to believe
that the story in the manuscript was coming true.
The current of its narrative had taken me deeper and deeper
into dark waters.
Alice had been taken from me.
Barry was probably in jail.
I was a fugitive from the FBI.
over by the dark presence trying to destroy me it all felt
real but it matched a textbook case of insanity I don't
think so I think everybody else is also dealing with what
you're dealing with so this tree looks suspicious no okay
sorry I I just had to get out of my curiosity it's dead yeah
but like look at
for like maybe if i accidentally miss a manuscript page or
something you know oh there we go on the road again rough
road i can handle it i can't work to get on the road again
see i'm gonna check in here
actually insanity isn't the thing in medicine It's a legal
term.
Ooh, you tell him, you tell him.
Wait, we can change cars?
No stinking way.
That's kind of crazy.
Carry my, carry my.
Oh, that's so cute.
You watch him actually get over.
Wait, I just...
I literally was just like, nah.
I'm done with that car.
I want this car instead.
Wait, I just stole another car.
Whoa, why did I do that?
Can I even drive it anymore?
Like, it seems like it's...
Um, the road is closed.
Or?
I make my own roads.
Yeah.
Alan be driving?
GTA Forest?
Keep going.
We're off-roading?
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Oh, we're fine.
Tis a scratch.
Tis about to scratch.
We're okay.
Oh, what's happening to my interface?
Did you guys see that?
Um.
Can I take this car, too?
Hey, this is Pat Main, and you're listening to KBF FM.
Folks, I want to apologize for kind of abandoning you to
that looping music track last night, but I was detained.
Detained?
They took...
I encountered a big-shot G-Man with an itchy trigger finger
who could use a lesson in manners and a boot in the ass.
Yeah.
Not necessarily in that order either.
Now, folks, I know I'm not being very informative here, and
I apologize for that.
G-Man.
I really should just keep quiet, but...
I'm just so peeved right now.
Because some people just shouldn't be carrying badges.
Oh!
You tell him.
I'm just glad that our Sheriff Breaker was there to
straighten things out.
I know, oh my god, poor man would have been shot probably.
I'm sorry if my mouth got you in trouble.
I'm pretty sure you're not the bad guy here.
He's talking to us!
I hope you know what you're doing.
He's a Chino, thank you!
I'll be talking to Dr. Nelson all morning.
But first, a little music.
A little music.
He doesn't think we're the bad guy.
Even though I've just stolen a card about to steal three.
It doesn't think I'm the bad guy.
Well, he doesn't know.
My second name is Billy Eilish.
I'm the bad guy.
Wait, this is just a little shortcut.
I'm looking for manuscript pages real quick.
Have a safe flight, Rick.
I'm borrowing them.
Yeah, exactly.
I don't know.
What do you guys like more?
Which car?
Which car do you like more?
This one?
Or this one?
I kind of want to make it three for three.
The jeep?
Oh, well.
Are you getting dizzy yet?
I am.
The jeep is all terrain.
I agree, honestly.
Claims are not the bad guy, despite stealing three cars,
causing property damage by blowing up gas tanks and fighting
a bulldozer.
Self-defense!
I claim it.
all right here we go bye other car the person's gonna come
back and be like how did my sorry it's a little it's a
little sensitive i'm not trying to i'm really not trying to
run us off the bridge that's a rock um gonna be like how did
my car get down here i put it in break didn't i to they
probably give you the options of the cars in case you were
like i can run this and then you're like wow this is really
far holy cow is this really stinking far oh my god we got
another car here it's like hot potato about the license
plate from earlier mount st helens was called the west
before it blew up.
Really?
When did it blow up?
Grand Theft Allen.
I hear another radio.
Welcome back to KBF FM.
KBF FM.
Now, Doc, you were talking about life and finding that
special someone, that soulmate.
Well, you were talking about that.
I was saying, I don't what are we talking about to me that's
strange because I always think he was a hopeless romantic in
the 80s you got me there Pat but I think love's where you
look for it and you need to do a lot of looking sure but the
idea that there's that one special person out there for you
oh wow means a romantic it's gone forever and you're forever
incomplete I mean isn't that depressing or child-achieving
there's a how do you fish in the sea and apparently a
fisherman has a fishing analogy for what you're saying isn't
that a little harsh well no what I am saying is that your
potential for finding that connection isn't limited to
what's essentially a chance encounter how is that harsh yeah
well old geezers are talking about they talking about okay
now well I don't disagree with you exactly but I can't
really fit that together with what I feel what I what I felt
for someone because she was the one she was oh my god I let
her drift away from me oh my god maybe I didn't put in the
work I don't know but well since then and it's a doctor and
therapist but since then there hasn't been anyone not like
her and I'm not saying I dwell on her or haven't moved on I
like my life I'm not living in the past but i do miss the
way she completed me oh you can't argue with the heart pat
uh i'm sorry folks i had kind of a scary experience oh let's
just say it's shaken a few things loose
dang pat you're you'll find your special someone
all right let's steal another car
He's been through it.
It's our fault.
I'm so sorry.
I don't like when I put it in reverse.
It like does this.
It flips the camera around on me.
I know how to reverse a car without going into.
Without, you know.
It being totally.
Where are these places in here?
I can go in here.
Oh my gosh.
me more.
Who hurt you, Pai?
Oh, wait, right, it was Nightingale.
Yeah.
There's so much to explore!
Wow.
Wait, can we go in, like, this whole town?
This whole mining area?
Oh, this don't seem safe.
Not one bit.
Is this the museum?
Oh, this doesn't look like it's an operation, but, um...
Oh, be careful.
Uh, hello?
I hope my soulmate watches VTubers.
I think they do.
I knew it, I knew it, I knew it, I knew it.
Let's see, where is this?
Mott on the ferry.
For Mott, spying on the rider on the ferry had been a
disappointment.
His boss had made Wake Out to be something special.
impressed he'd gotten a good long look up the wife though
and he liked what he saw mod had fantasized about going wake
into a fight but it hadn't happened still he'd get his
chance to see if the writer had anything in him he'd been
promised as much um is that the kidnapper he's got a name
what look at this place wow okay i'm scared now
Mott.
This isn't open, right?
Just looks like it should.
I almost want to go in there.
Okay.
We keep driving?
My poor wife.
She's waiting.
Maybe.
He was the grumpy creeper on the boat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember him.
He's the kidnapper, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The alleged kidnapper.
I guess he really is the kidnapper.
Oh, watch for the tree.
Oh.
Drifto!
Visitor parking.
I was early.
I was supposed to meet the kidnapper at noon in the main
building.
The coal mine was quiet.
It was a museum now.
This doesn't seem...
seem safe for anybody.
I was going to say for like civilians, but it don't seem
safe for anyone.
It looks like it's like the sun is already setting.
If this is noon, what's this say?
I thought of something, you guys, for next week.
Because kind of going on like my little, showing the like
dinosaur tangent and everything.
One thing I wanted to do a long time ago was back because of
I haven't looked into if places still do this, but I still
want to do it next week if they still do.
But that was part of what I was going to do today.
But museums had like virtual museum things that you could
like tour the museum just virtually.
And so I wanted us to go on some virtual museum tours.
And we'll learn some stuff.
They still do that!
Oh yeah!
Let's do it.
Well, there were some earlier residents in the area.
The true genesis of the town of Bright Falls came with the
founding of the Bright Falls Mining Company and the opening
of the Bright Falls Coal Mine in 1878.
Although the work was hard and dangerous, many immigrants,
Germans, Poles, Italians, Finns and Swedes, among others,
worked in the mines.
What did I say?
Oh, just the mine museum.
I see you.
Dinosaur tour, maybe.
I was going to find some cool places.
While lucrative at first, the mining steadily declined in
the 20th century.
The seams were rich, but hard to get at.
And the volcanic activity in the area made the mine shafts
particularly dangerous.
Oh, the sun's coming out.
Tomorrow.
I've reached the checkpoint.
But you're mine.
I'm done.
Oh, da, da.
Tomorrow.
There we are.
Now I'm just looking at the museum part.
Wait, what's this say?
I'm reading.
In 1970, a volcanic eruption below Cauldron Lake, while
relatively minor, caused most of the deep mining tunnels to
collapse or flood.
32 miners lost their lives in the calamity.
And all mining around Bright Falls came to a final stop.
Now, many of the remaining buildings are protected as
historical landmarks.
Oh!
I almost missed that.
Okay.
Sarah in the radio station.
With Nightingale gone and the night wind blowing in through
the broken studio window, Maine stared at Sarah.
The sheriff looked away.
Maine's voice shook with barely controlled anger.
Ooh.
That boy's doing more drinking than thinking.
And how many adults?
I hope you know what you're doing, Sarah.
He's got a sickness in his eyes.
You take my word for it.
He wants wake for a reason, and it's not for anything good.
Yeah, do we even know why this guy is here?
Mint reading all the local history learned nothing major.
call me a canary the way i'll be whistling in that mine
whoa whoa you can make it oh gosh cutscene is this the main
building i guess i didn't want to go outside cops had to be
looking for me
turned the place into a sauna the day dragged on different
scenarios ran through my mind ways of how i'd torture the
kidnapper to get alice back or the different horrible things
he could have done to her i imagined her dead no i had no
way of knowing she was still alive it was killing me uh
aren't we supposed to meet at noon i was running on blind
it's like nighttime now oh my god it was all a waste of time
the bastard never showed up Maybe he's dead.
We waited all day!
Alan wait, then Alan rage.
Wake.
Where the hell are you?
Change of plans.
You know where Mirror Peak is?
It's a big mountain north of where you are.
You follow the path from the mine you can't miss it.
There's a lookout point there.
Oh my god.
I'm through being jerked around by you.
You want to see your wife alive?
Because if you do, you better watch what you say to me.
Do we understand each other?
I want to talk to Alice Yeah, and I want the manuscript
Don't keep me waiting, Wake Oh my god Hello I'm gonna kill
him I had to get to Mirror Peak No Why is this a guy's
obsession Yeah
What's happening?
It was close Oh my god God, that scared the hell out of me.
How do I get out of here?
Oh my gosh.
I'm lost.
How did I get in here?
Do I go up?
Alan's stuck?
Yeah.
Alan trapped.
Do I go down?
Do I jump down?
Oh!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
There probably was a better way.
I saw a green light over here.
Oh, I see it there.
I'm stuck.
Oh.
Ah, dang.
I really thought that would be a light.
Really thought...
Oh, I can't bring any more...
more batteries.
You know what, maybe that's okay.
We tap 20.
That's a lot.
I see a manuscript down there.
My knees.
It was like a bit of a slide, and we just uh... He's just
old.
He couldn't... I can tank it.
He can't tank it.
Alright, let's go.
Through here.
I'm guessing there's a ladder?
No, we just Hmph!
Hmph!
Whoa, down there.
Um, nobody touched me.
I'm being a nerd.
Okay, nobody touched me.
I need to read.
My, my show is on.
Thomas Zane in love with Barbara...
Barbara...
When Thomas Zane fell for Barbara Jagger, it happened fast.
She was young, vibrant, and beautiful, full of life.
He had never been a very happy man and without any seeming
effort.
She had changed all that Zane felt good for the first time
in his life Everything she did was another piece of a jigsaw
puzzle.
He hadn't even known he'd been missing and best of all She
made the words flow strong and sharp.
She was his muse.
She was his muse
What was there anything else up?
Oh, no, okay Music sounding real bad around here.
Real creepy stuff going on.
The weather.
Look, you can still see the stars, though.
With all this fog, it's kind of impressive.
Pick up revolver.
Thank you very much.
Pick up.
Oh, no.
We have the...
No!
We have the dumpster of ammo.
That means bad things are surely going to happen.
Ow!
Oh gosh, this guy.
Oh my god!
Yeah, get his butt, get his butt, get his butt.
Ow!
Oh.
Oh shoot.
Okay,
we got the big guy.
No!
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh, God!
This one too!
I'm going back for ammo.
Now we have to deal with guys.
We have to deal with...
We have to deal with so much!
Evil mine cart!
Wait, like all the spooky went away though.
That's cool, that's good.
Oh, that's not the right way.
I think through here is the right lane.
Flashbangs!
Oh yeah!
Flashbangs, my beloved!
We'll equip the flashbangs over the flares for now.
Players are great too though, don't get me wrong.
And you thought.
You thought, eh?
Oh gosh, who's gonna come out here?
I need to go forward.
This is a museum?
How?
How do people get through here?
How do people navigate?
They were wearing Adidas.
Yeah, they looked very modern, didn't they?
Oh.
Oh, this is good.
It's gonna destroy the thing.
Wait, can I get up here?
Hello?
Oh, I open it up.
Wait, that sounds like a stupid idea.
Where's the other one?
Okay.
Why is...
Why are the poles sparking everywhere?
Oh my god.
Is this place not maintained at all?
Like...
What is this?
This is the...
Anyway.
Alan's stand.
Alan takes a stand.
Where am I?
Where do I go?
Alan I, Joe.
Be there, be there, be there, My wife got kidnapped a long
time ago.
Where did we came from somewhere?
But where did she go?
Where did she go?
What?
Alan Wake's wife.
What I miss?
Just heard a door open.
Sounds like a big lot of commotion in there, out here.
I only did what any logical person would do, which is shut
the door and wait for it to go away.
Okay, this will probably be a checkpoint, and then we're
going to get ambushed.
I got my flashbangs on.
The only way to reach the hillside ahead was to go through
the building.
I had to find a way to avoid electrocution.
Oh, love that.
Okay.
Oh, I can't drive this.
Okay, wait, can I...
Rubber...
Um...
Rubber your tires.
Who is coming over it?
Who's coming out?
I'm scared.
Wait, hey, hey.
We've managed to avoid electrocution.
Okay, this seems kind of...
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to go back to the car.
I'm taking the car.
Uh-oh.
Holy ambush!
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
Eyes out of it!
Okay, that's a bit scary, so I'm scared.
Maybe I can kill them though.
To the light!
Hold on, I'll kill them all.
My road rage, yeah.
Are
you...
Yeah!
Off the power.
I don't like the sound of that, though.
Anybody laughed?
Doesn't seem like it.
The car is OP.
It's my favorite thing.
The car is...
A little worse for where?
It'll be okay, right?
It's only...
Smoking a tiny tad.
Checkpoint reached.
Flare gun.
Okay.
No, I don't want that right now.
Thank you.
But I will reload you.
And reload you.
Alright.
Everything's reloaded.
Everything's just...
Toji, good to go.
Nothing over here.
Alright, let's turn off the power then.
Okay, that wouldn't break.
It would just turn off the power.
Oh my god, this thing is...
Not doing so high.
Oh my god!
We lost the car!
Okay, I was getting a preemptive, like maybe something
would, you know...
Where'd the other thing go?
that was attacking me though.
Did I kill it?
Oh no!
Oh shoot!
We're in trouble.
We're in big trouble.
We're in big trouble!
Oh shoot guys, we're in big trouble.
Oh, it
starts there?
Oh shoot.
Guys, we're in big trouble.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe we do this.
The...
The big things that are gonna start attacking us.
Like that, right?
Not one of them?
No?
Do they only start coming out when I'm in the car?
That's so mean!
Akashite!
Thank you so much for the gift of daycare!
Oh, geez.
Okay, um...
It's just so difficult to drive the car!
I'll try.
I'm just gonna run now.
Insane driving.
Tank it!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Ouch!
Drive, please!
Ouch, oh my god.
Oh shit!
Please go!
Holy... Holy cow!
We made it!
By the skin or by the hair of our chinny chin chin.
That was intense.
That was kind of insane.
Holy cow.
Good job.
Yeah.
No.
I thought that was a thermos!
All right.
I keep hearing a door opening.
And also, how do I get up there?
What?
Did I hear a...
No?
Okay, just kidding.
Is there...
a way to climb?
Huh!
Hmm.
Maybe climb here.
And jump somewhere.
Can I jump there?
Oh, wait.
Maybe these.
And.
Okay.
Just kidding.
What the heck?
How am I supposed to get up there?
Oh,
I hate this.
Oh, I thought it was, like, gonna be 10 guys.
Well.
Uh.
I did darn mess that up.
No.
The checkpoint.
But my flare.
My flashbang, I mean.
So sad.
There's...
There's also, like, exploding things in here.
Hey, where are you going?
I shot the one in the back.
I guess I missed.
I really did think I shot that one, though, right there.
The tracksuits are too funny.
They're so stylish.
Like, why are they...
They're, like, coming in flexing on me.
They look like...
Like, a stylish gang or something.
So funny.
anyways that would have been a perfect time for the trust no
one in the dark do you guys hear that that wasn't me walking
that's scary I heard footsteps upstairs
um this is another one of these situations where oh oh it's
a I thought okay I was pushing that over seeing if it would
like create a ramp There we go.
I'm not going to get ambushed, am I?
What footsteps was I hearing?
Follow.
Yeah, I got that.
I think that's the only way I can go.
Fancy chair.
Quite out of place.
You hear it?
It scared me.
um oh this one wake touched by the dark presence some of the
taken retained echoes of their former selves but these were
just the nerve twitches of a dead thing nothing remained but
a shell covered and filled with darkness in most cases these
puppets were enough for the purposes of the dark presence
but for anything more elaborate as with the writer it was
different it needed his mind completely it merely touched
him wow touched i'm touched honestly i'm touched okay
interesting yeah it needs my brain power to to um keep
writing all right who's up there i'm still here Okay, hold
on, I'm surveying the area.
There's something there that's shining.
And a light, perhaps?
And, oh, there's that shack right there.
Because I didn't get like a checkpoint, so I'm like...
Who is up there?
Oh, shoot!
Oh!
One second!
who's in here oh i need that thing all right hold on
batteries oh okay hold on hope you're enjoying alan wake
yeah i really am it's a lot of fun
so that will open this okay and then we'll get ambushed got
it i know how this works now i know your games game
Okay, let's go do it.
Oh, this one.
I know it's probably gonna be a very slow gate too.
There was no way the flashbang grenades were standard power
company equipment.
Shocking.
What?
Oh my god.
Huh.
Fascinating.
Okay, so I need to go this way?
But like, what's that direction?
There's also that thing up there.
We're reaching mirror peak.
I feel like I need to look over here for a manuscript.
Alas.
Maybe yellow?
Nothing.
Okay, never mind.
Seems normal to be.
Oh, it was the goop!
I forgot about the goop.
I was like, what am I attacking right now?
Oh yeah, there's goop on the ground.
Yeah, be gone?
Be gone?
Oh, the checkpoint.
Okay, cool.
Any more goop around?
that goop if oh oh yes we do freshly stocked goop is that
scoop no okay I want to get all of it because if we have to
run back this way for whatever reason I don't want to get
hurt you know oh gosh I didn't even see that guy
yeah oh more of Oh shoot,
I didn't mean to...
Ah, big
go!
Yeah!
Yeah, cinematic.
Dodge.
Oh my god, oh my god.
You're too powerful!
Whop!
Ouchie, ouchie!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, we almost died.
Holy...
Oh, let's just stand here for a second and recover a bit.
Holy cow.
Prepare for trouble and make you devil.
Oh, let's let everything recharge.
Recharge?
Feel better?
Okay, my health is still slowly but surely.
Oh, barely made it.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't want to waste all my flashbangs, though.
Those guys are so tanky.
They're extremely tanky.
hello potion seller I'm going into battle and I want your
strongest potions you cannot handle my potions no more
shotgun I do have it probably would be better for those big
guys anyway you guys I don't know what's going on sometimes
you know Chitan like the mascot occasionally she'll just
like like my tweets I don't why it's
so funny like sometimes i'll just get a notification that's
like cheetah and liked your tweet and i'm like really how
are you finding me so curious freak to freak communication
sounds about right okay let's take let's make bets guys who
thinks alice is alive raise your hand Wake and bury in the
cell.
I stared through the bars of the jail cell.
Barry stood behind me.
No, when did we get locked up?
As I felt.
Agent Nightingale stood on the other side of the bars with
Sheriff Breaker.
Nightingale had a stack of manuscript pages in his hand.
He seemed unhinged as he gloated.
Well, I've got you now, Raymond Chandler.
It's all here.
All the evidence, including conspiracy to murder a federal
agent.
What?
It's a book!
You'd say Alice is alive?
I'll see it to believe it.
Okay, checkpoint, thank goodness.
Spooky.
Oh wait, it's actually like guiding.
It's guiding me in the direction I need to go.
Wait, that was so...
But what's up there?
Oh, it looks like a Tori gate.
Yellow.
Am I going to get ambushed, though?
I just hit a checkpoint if I do get ambushed.
This way.
Oh my gosh, we're going through.
Ooh.
This way.
What do we got?
American Tori gate.
All right.
More flashbangs.
We're a big fan of those.
Oh yeah.
Oh okay.
You tried.
And flashbang!
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Please!
Oh my god!
What's wrong with my...
trying to like...
Maneuver but... Oh my god.
There we go.
I got all tripped up.
We're fine.
Okay, we got ambushed, but it wasn't so bad.
Could have been worse.
Could have been much worse.
Oh, thermos.
Do I have to jump for this?
Oh, no.
Wait, I have to, like...
Skill check for the thermos?
Oh.
Look, we got this.
Skill check.
Oh, please.
Thank you.
Please pick it up, Alan.
Please, Alan.
Alan.
No, don't do that.
Oh, God.
Get in the light.
Get in the light, you bozo.
What the heck?
Okay.
All right.
We'll go back to my revolver for now.
Oh, we do have shot.
was going to say unless we get more shotgun ammo.
Love that for us.
Oh, I'm out of room for batteries.
Okay.
Can't complain.
That means I have a lot of batteries.
All stocked up.
That does concern me.
I'm going to see if we reach a checkpoint over here, going
through here.
I don't think so.
I was hoping.
There was a shred of hope.
I had no real plan.
I was going to give the kidnapper all the manuscript pages I
had for Alice.
If that wasn't enough, I'd hold him at gunpoint and make him
talk.
Comp action shotgun.
Whoa.
What is this?
There's something that way.
We like it.
I really wish I get a checkpoint, but just keep running.
Keep on going.
It's scaring me.
Wait!
Hmm.
I think YouTube just died completely.
Oh no!
Wait, why?
Oh my god, there's more!
Why?
Oh, why did I do that?
What?
Oh my gosh, I tried to dodge.
I saw it.
Oh my gosh!
I'm running towards the light.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Holy cow.
Oh.
More!!!!!
Okay, do I just need to go?
Because like, what the hell is this?
Do I just need to run?
Oh my gosh, yeah.
Kick your asses.
Oh, press- press play?
Press play!
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Press play!
Why do they keep showing up?
The thermos I see you!
Wait, is there light in there?
Maybe it's worth...
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Ah!
Oh, okay, this was the checkpoint right here.
Okay.
I think I just need to keep running.
They just don't stop.
Died so close to the light.
They start running through the light though, they do.
If that wasn't enough, I'd hold him at gunpoint and make him
talk.
Keep running, running.
I think that's my only option.
Okay, alright, let's go.
Otherwise, it's just...
You guys get in the light?
I'm stuck on a rock.
What?
Ouch.
Nice.
Double kill.
Yeah.
Assholes.
Okay, keep running.
Keep running.
Running, running, running, running, running.
Running, running, running, running.
Is this another light right here?
I don't actually know where I'm going.
I'm just running and running.
Okay.
Yeah, there's more guys.
We get it.
Oh, there's a lot of guys.
Turn it on!
Oh, she's...
Oh, this is so bad.
Oh.
This is tough.
I had no real plan.
Nice parry.
I was going to give the kidnapper all the many discrepancies
I had for Alice.
Oh, I can.
If that wasn't enough, I'd hold him at gunpoint and make him
talk.
And make him talk.
Yeah, yeah.
This one.
Yeah, I should have flashbanged.
I meant...
to and in my brain i just you know i got overwhelmed it
happens
whoa geez
running running running running running running running
running running running running
so many guys oh please i get it turn on the thing turn on
the thing turn on the light there we go and flashback oh
yeah oh i don't know why i hit him yeah you want some ideas
All right.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're my safety.
Turn back on.
Turn on.
Okay.
We're just gonna keep going.
Oh, don't turn off.
Please.
The dark presence was moving ahead of me in the same
direction I was going.
A cold feeling settled at in the pit of my stomach was it
going for Alice that don't look good also all these graves a
little freaky I do wonder if these places are like
maintained still oh the graveyard shift may cause cancer
what oh my god you're fast oh no you're one of these types
oh my god no
Oh my gosh, there's more than one!
Flashbang!
Oh my god, I'm trying to...
You!
A graveyard shift!
And...
Oh my god, I can't get him.
What are you doing?
Yeah.
That's right.
why would it cause cancer
okay I'm gonna let myself recharge a little bit he got stuck
recharge just a tad
give me one second guys I just spilled water all over myself
one second
I need to get that right I had to get I'm like a napkin.
Oopsie.
Okay.
We're back at it.
Cells go crazy from stress.
Is that true?
Oh geez.
Oh my god, I got it all over my dress and everything.
I think I'm potentially headed the right direction.
Use?
Oh!
We love it!
Oh yes, yes, yes, yes!
Not stress, it's the coal in this context.
Oh, wait, we just double checkpointed?
Interesting.
I thought this thing was gonna become darkness.
Hello?
Was that that that just fell?
I don't know.
In the second episode, there was that dog, right?
I don't know why we thought, why I thought we would have a
dog in this game.
I wonder if it's because of John Wick.
The place was dead, a ghost town, had been for decades,
maybe a century.
Oh, that's weird.
What the?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, chill.
I'll get you.
Hey.
That was close!
Holy cow.
We barely made that.
Evil car.
Okay.
I like to wait for my flashlight to reload, you know.
Is there anything in there?
Looks like a whole lot of nothing.
Wait, is there like a staircase here?
No, it's a wall.
Looking for more manuscript pages, please.
Oh, the...
Oh, speaking, you shall receive.
I think I...
I can't tell if I missed it.
I know they kind of like show up random, not in order all
the time, so you're like, we got this one.
But I wonder if I missed that.
Things were never as simple in real life as in fiction.
count of the times I had wished there'd be a clear reason
for my writer's block.
Something to fight.
Something to lash out on.
There wasn't.
I was filled with doubt.
I was nothing like the hero in my books.
Alex Casey had gone through his life with single-minded
determination.
Never wavering from his goal.
Even now, I was angry at myself.
Angry at Alice.
Angry at Barry.
I was fumbling and I had no plan.
Why are you angry at Alice?
What did she do?
Oh my gosh, misplaced anger.
for real what the hell i was angry at my wife for not giving
me ideas oh i thought i needed to jump that how dare she go
and get kidnapped you know what that sounds like a great
great uh inspiration for another book cray payer oh gray
peak Gray Peak Gorge Gray Pear Originally founded in 1928
The Gray Peak Gorge mining town Was one of the permanent
settlements Of the Bright Falls mining company Built for its
workers The nearby graveyard is a testament To the dangers
the miners faced on a daily basis Most of the men who lost
their lives the years we're burnt we're we're here last wait
over the years here where we're we're buried there english
is hard a grim reminder to be careful for those who remained
gray peak gorge was a a
abandoned over almost overnight when the bright falls mining
company closed its doors in
I can read.
I promise.
It is really cool, though, that, like, you see an area and
most likely you're going to go to it.
Like, it feels very...
Like, you know, the game itself feels really cool in that.
Come on, you can do it!
Like, open world positive.
It's pretty fun.
Thermos?
My everything.
Wait, there's some more stuff over here too.
Battery, which I don't need.
This Alan can't use his arms.
What's in here?
Dark Souls is like that too.
I'm sure.
I'm sure it is.
Noodle arms.
Look, he's a geek.
He can't help it.
I'm like hearing so many noises I'm just trying to find
pages I'm also hearing like which makes me think there's a
secret nearby let's see can we get inside here doesn't seem
like it okay it's awfully quiet he's a rider there's a
difference so I have to cross the ghost town and
sick beat oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot where's the
other one right there oh out out out out oh my god three of
them okay
I think for that one I need to uh do the what's it called
the that bad boy this guy right here wait am I going the
right way this way this away and then there were more
batteries in that building so once we're done with these
guys we can yeah flashback The flare bang.
Flare, God would be good here.
Oh, you're right.
I think it's...
Oh!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
Chill out.
For these two, though, I don't mind.
Oh!
It went out of bounds, so it doesn't count.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god!
Oh, come on!
My biggest enemy is the...
It's the tag.
It always puts me backwards.
The inanimate objects.
It's because I'm like trying to tank them.
Okay.
There you go, there we go.
All right, let me let my flashlight.
Let me let my flashlight redo.
And then we'll just hide behind this guinea bull's little
string bean, string bean, Allen string bean here.
All right.
I guess my Flare missed before And that's why it didn't work
I'm assuming
Okay, can I run?
Oh my gosh Oh, dang it
Woo Time
They're so annoying And so stupid at the same time
There's just There's They annoy me!
Okay.
Stupid and annoying go hand in hand.
Not always.
Sometimes.
I think you can be annoying but not stupid.
But I think most stupid people are annoying.
You know what I mean.
How much more of this chapter do I have?
golly all right keep it going keep it coming
that didn't sound good
uh let's go back to my gun even let's agree to disagree here
okay
train okay Oh,
there's another bit.
You're okay.
Oh,
Yeah, a little more.
There we go.
What was that game?
Choo-choo Charles or something about the evil...
The evil...
Train.
Got flashbacks.
Alright, I don't want to waste these so much either, too,
so.
Pick up.
What did I grab?
Oh, a key!
Okay, interesting.
Choo-choo taros!
It was pretty fun from what I remember.
Silly horror is so good at the same time.
love me a really creepy horror but silly horror is also so
good okay it's like I'm constantly trying the the door knob
oh yes yes more flare gun ammo yes yes good yes yes oh
anything outside of riding is a struggle I feel ill I
managed to make my way downstairs there's a shoebox filled
with books and papers by thomas zane it's very hard to say
for action managed to read some of it he's a poet and a good
one he writes of muses and creators summoning fabulous
things from a magic lake using his powers to shape the world
of a realm of gods and dreams and demons dark things that
wait for a chance to slip through wearing the flesh of men
as disguise zane writes about himself his girlfriend being
taken over by a dark presence About growing scared of the
lake.
Zane believes it's a mirror to the gaping void of darkness
above.
Where some love crafty and presence lurks.
I crawled back upstairs.
I'll borrow these things from my story.
They ring true.
They fit.
His face.
Mr. Wake, are you okay?
Oh, what's this?
Oh, wait.
We can only have either the, uh, what's it called, right?
Which would be better?
The shotgun that I have, or is the hunting rifle better?
Alan plagiarized.
Hunting rifle is one shot.
It is?
I don't, wait, how much, how many bullets do I have for a
shotgun?
Honestly, I have 15 versus, uh, 11.
So...
Alright, here we go.
I'm scared.
Oh.
Darkness!
Anyway.
Don't come out of there.
How much more!
This chapter does drag.
Let's see.
Oh?
Who?
Secret?
Where?
Be do, be do.
The kidnapper had sent me a text.
The message was full of spelling errors and insults.
It was telling me to hurry up.
Calm down.
I'm trying to find the secret passage.
Oh, it's got to be this way.
Yeah.
Nice.
Alan Wake would never yes nice he would never ever ever
plagiarize he wouldn't do that to us and all that we've
worked hard for right Alan Wake Alan Loop Loot Goblin unless
no
nice Alan Wake is gonna like birds birds oh shoot not the
birds he's gonna he's gonna be like I have a crazy idea for
a thing it's called like weirder creatures weirder stuff you
know I'm never stranger things what's that no no I'm talking
about weirder stuff my original idea my original TV show
where's the bird show
Holy banger.
Why am I not attacking them?
Unusual items.
They're too far?
They're pretty close to me.
This is close.
This is close, and it's still not getting them.
Maybe I need to keep going, and then they start coming after
me.
Maybe it's one of those situations.
Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
It's like a time thing.
Oh, the currances.
No, no, more than...
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Get your barge.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
It's scary.
It's scarier when they do the thematic stuff like that.
Competitions for big chairs.
What the heck does that mean?
Bird, bird, bird, birds, birds, birds attacking.
They're coming after you and you gotta run and run and run.
Oh, never mind.
We're going into the mines?
That doesn't seem very safe.
Okay.
We're doing this.
Why?
This seems like the actual worst idea that we ever could
have had.
Exit the silver mine.
Gladly.
What?
Alan mine?
But do Alan craft?
Tunnels?
Tunnels to Cauldron Lake.
Oh!
Alice?
What?
Are you down here?
Tunnels go to Cauldron Lake.
Okay.
Without looning,
the headache stabbed at my brain.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm coming.
Alice?
Oh my god.
I'm coming.
I'm losing it.
I gotta get out of here.
Is that the lake?
What if I go in?
He faked out.
He was like, I'm gonna do it.
No, just kidding.
Let's see what we got here.
Hunters taken.
The hunters were big, thick-set men, confident and at home
in the woods.
They were feeling good, running on beer and ghost stories
and camaraderie late into the night.
It did them no good, as they were taken by the dark
presence, sucked deep into a darkness far worse than any
ghost story they ever Yeah, those guys suck.
We do not like the hunters.
I'm guessing those are like the big, big guys that I've been
fighting.
Hmm.
That was a little fun detour.
I liked that.
Quite spooky and interesting.
So that was the lake though.
Like that was just that it looked like a like a tar pit.
Mmm, soup.
Spokely.
You know, what scary stories are they talking about?
I wonder what ghost stories they have.
Okay.
We're still trying to...
We're back in the mines.
Trying to figure out where my wife went.
My...
Was that in the game or was that my computer?
Sorry, I'm double checking down here.
Okay, nothing.
There was like a creaking noise.
It was in the game.
Okay, good.
I was like, uh-oh.
What's going on with like a fever?
Let's switch to our flares, actually.
Oh, I was like, what's that?
That light.
Shining light.
And some more ammo.
and stuff that does not instill confidence in me that
something won't happen in here
more pages i think i missed two dang it i think i really did
even behind the closed doors and curtains of his grimy room
at the majestic the local motel nightingale could feel the
locals eyes on him the unrelenting pressure of their
judgment he forced it out of his mind for all he knew they
Wake's spell already.
You do what you have to do to get the job done.
He took comfort from the bottom of his hand.
Please, he thought.
Just let me get through this.
My, wait, Alan Wake's spell?
What am I, a witch?
Like, some are behind the hardest difficulty, but it's only
the ones with the little symbols that you see here.
So there's these two that I feel like I missed.
But other three, five left.
Five left.
Here, oh.
That looks like the way out.
Uh-oh.
Uh-huh.
It's not gonna collapse on us, is it?
Okay.
Oh,
shoot.
Where are you?
Actually, the player kind of...
Woo!
Yeah!
Ooh!
Hunting rifles good!
Ouch, I tried to dodge.
Nice.
Nice!
Oh, not nice.
so not nice good shot thank you thank you team i would like
to thank oh my goodness my flashlight for for uh let's now
wait what's happening oh i'm getting a visual glitch again
at least i can like fix that very easily oh i forgot that i
didn't use my revolver at all You can fix the visual glitch
very easily by just pausing and continuing.
Okay.
Thermus.
This is the remaster, yeah.
Does it?
I mean, I imagine the remaster looks better than the
original, no?
Is it that difficult to tell?
Because I've had several people asking, like, is this the
remaster or not?
Alan Explorer.
I can't tell really that's so interesting wait okay never
mind that's a collapse it's not that different I'd have to
make my way up this mineshaft in order to go on maybe the
machinery could help me with that okay sure still looks like
an old game to me I guess that's fair
There we go.
That's better maybe.
Nice.
Jump!
Clap.
Yeah, this is a remaster.
Alan, jump!
Hmm.
Wee!
Prefer that it's a minimal remaster?
I don't mind it at all either.
You know, I never played...
Where am I trying to get to?
I didn't play the original, obviously.
But I'm still enjoying myself.
Where?
I'm trying to get to this platform, no?
I don't think I can reach it, though, even if I jump.
A lot of changes in the details and why, then.
Oh, maybe I go over there.
Oh, I see what I'm supposed to do.
Okay, no, just kidding.
There we go.
Wait!
Hemp!
I got it.
Wait, what's up here, though?
I played the OG one recently since it was what I had, and
honestly, it doesn't look that much.
different.
I already explained before, but this one was free for me,
so, um, that's why I'm playing this one, but, uh, it still
does not look bad to me at all, or it has, it has played
fine.
I'm having, I'm enjoying it.
Okay.
Let's maneuver this now.
Oh, easy.
Free is my favorite price.
Yeah, baby.
But I think some people were saying that you can get the
original on Steam for like a few bucks.
So that's
always a good deal too.
I'm usually one to like want to play original versions of a
game.
But...
Wait, where did this take me?
Wait.
So we got up here.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Oh, okay, okay.
That's where we need to go.
Hempf.
There we go.
I believe two is only on Epic.
And I think when I got the first one...
Or not...
Sorry, when I bought two...
It gave me one for free.
Or maybe they were both free.
I don't know.
I feel like I got it for like some special deal.
Alan humph.
He got a lot.
He got that humph in him.
Like.
Yay.
Checkpoint.
Am I out of the mines?
Oh, I think we actually are.
Let's go.
Oh, kick.
Alan kick.
Yeah.
Reach the peak.
It's peak, everybody.
It's peak.
What's down here?
Alan Explore.
Actually, I think the peak might be over there, so hold on.
Oh, what just happened?
Hello?
That was weird.
Alan?
Alan, you got some weird stuff going on.
That was bizarre.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, this is a visual.
Oh my gosh, I'm getting a lot of the visual glitches today
though.
I focus.
Wow.
What am I looking?
Is that the peak right there?
The little, little like point that looks like it's Pride
Rock.
The Yudukab.
Tor hits Nurse Sinclair.
Lightning flash behind the windows of Calderon Lake Lodge.
Tor Anderson laughed and held the stealing number above his
head.
Uh oh.
Nurse Sinclair was trying to come in.
him down without success tour grinned madly and shouted my
hammer's up here's a friendly poke from molnir wench oh my
god hammer down with all his might on sinclair's head we're
on a comeback tour baby oh that doesn't sound good oh boy i
like how dramatic this is
just seem a little...
Like, so big, you know, your problems are so small compared
to how the world is, the size of the world.
Anything else over here?
Nothing?
Okay.
That was a nice little detour as well.
Reach the mirror peak lookout.
Surely, I'm not gonna have another issue.
like at lover's peak.
Right?
Please, God, no.
I don't want to go through it again.
Oh, the bird, you're right.
Yeah, I'm taking out these birds.
Oh!
You guys are going to be extinct by the time!
Oh, it's the bird music again.
Bird, bird.
Bird, bird, it's happening.
And there they go, yep.
As fast as they can.
More flares!
Oh.
Oh, you're right.
I didn't even think about it.
Oh, great.
You're so right.
This one will go better.
These are so unsafe.
Like, everything in this game is an OSHA...
Nightmare, I fear.
Where are they?
Oh!
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow!
They're aggressive.
Look!
Oh my god!
I wish I could turn around faster to kill these guys.
Oh my god.
Almost
there maybe?
Flare him.
Oh my god, it's just one thing after another.
Oh my god, it's just one thing after another!
Oh.
I did not mean to do that, but it was awesome!
I did
not mean to use that.
It was just automatically equipped because I had a...
I could get around that.
We're fine.
You see?
Cinema indeed.
Oh, we don't even need more revolvers.
Was there anything up here?
Hey.
All right.
Oh.
Ambush here?
I
don't even know where I'm going.
I know where I'm going but I don't know.
Where are you guys?
Where are you?
What is this?
What is this formation here?
Oh there's something here though.
I'll take that for sure.
Ah there they are.
Sir?
I love the hunting rifle.
What?
Yeah.
I like the hunting rifle, I think.
Uh, is this not a light right here?
Oh, damn!
Oh, my God.
Anyway.
Come.
What did he throw at me?
Uh, cauldron lake!
Okay.
You're not gonna be behind me, are you?
Checkpoint reached!
Oh.
This looks kind of precarious now, don't it?
Oh, geez.
Okay, come on.
Nothing, just one step at a time.
Easy does it.
This Oshi body pillow, that's what it choked at me.
It's not the birds, is it?
Oh no, it's just a bunch of guys.
Oh, I'm so screwed.
Wait, uh, how are y'all?
Oh my god, the guy is like right behind me.
I don't mean to use flares, but honestly, it's fine.
whatever works, I suppose.
Oh, I didn't shoot him.
Oh, oh, big guy.
Oh, wait, I'm gonna fall off!
Big guy.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my God.
Oh, awkward.
Ouch!
Where are you?
Okay.
Oh, holy.
Yeah, I do have them, that's true.
Use them while I got them, huh?
I guess I only have two flash...
Uh...
Two flashbangs, so...
Oh.
Where?
This way?
Oh, over there?
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh, woo.
They're going and more and more and more and more.
Okay.
Alright.
We're going up.
This way.
Okay.
This...
This way.
I'm telling you, man, this place is so...
Everything is so run down.
Like, who...
A child is gonna die here.
Some kid's life, little...
Little, like, kid life mission is gonna be like, I wanna go
to the mining town, and they'll get there.
Mott had checked all of Stucky's rental cabins.
Where's Mott?
There had been no sign of the wakes.
It was dark when he'd found their car parked at the end of
the road by Cauldron Lake.
It made no sense.
They must have taken a wrong turn.
But there was no sign of them.
And the car had been there for hours already.
Frustrated.
Mott stood on the rotten ruin of the footbridge that had
once led to Diver's Isle before it sank beneath the waves
years ago.
The boss wouldn't be happy.
Timmy's stuck in the mines.
Like...
I really think I missed two pages.
No, how could I?
Dang it.
All right.
Shirley, we're almost to the peak.
Cross the mountain ruins.
Is that what this is now?
Whoa!
What is here?
Jump.
Alan, jump.
and push.
Oh!
Actually.
Wait, what's over here before we go too far?
The boss fight I skipped?
Oh, you think?
Maybe.
Maybe there was, like, one in there.
Alright.
It's not that I wanted to skip it.
It's just that it was skippable.
I think there's a difference.
Whoa!
Whoa, I like looking at the view.
This game is so cool looking.
Do I need to go in there?
I heard a pigeon.
I'll come back for you.
Wait.
Oh.
Jump.
Oh no.
in my bed oh shoot come on game i didn't even get to check
if the front door was open i guess not
cw and tz tom and tom
it's not adam and eve it's tom and tom
you talk to me on tv I miss you, Tom.
Did you write this?
Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom.
Oh, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom,
Tom, Tom.
I miss you, Tom.
I think someone's got a little crush on Tom.
Wait, there was something out.
Oh, you talked to me on TV.
I miss you, Tom.
Tom.
I think somebody's got a little crush.
Oh, this feels like horror for real now.
We're in, like, such a creepy building.
Revolver.
Uh, any green apple.
Over there.
I think the other one was shotgun, too.
Okay.
Don't like that!
Okay, if these are ruins, how truly old are they?
Like, it doesn't seem like such a old building.
Like, there's a lamp.
70s.
I feel like ruins belong for, like, something from the BC
era.
8,000 years old.
Yeah.
Hello?
Not hello.
There should be nobody here.
Oh, jeez.
And flare.
Another flare.
Oh, I should kill you first.
Yeah, yeah.
Stay away from me.
Stay away from me!
The corner strat.
The corner strat!
It's effective!
Oh, that's another big guy I just realized.
Oh, there's more?
Corner strat.
Oh my god, please.
No!
Why are you smart?
I just realized.
Ouch!
Yeah!
I'm gonna get you.
And one more.
Yeah, okay.
Just one guy left now.
Okay, we're good.
I could have used my flare gun, but...
Oh, I have one bullet left.
Nice.
I panicked.
Plain and simple.
I was scared.
And I forgot to switch weapons.
Okay.
They're here?
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
I should switch weapons now, though.
Let's do it.
Humpf.
Alan Humpf.
And the thermos.
One bullet left.
Why would they do this to me?
They're like, you're too good on that gun.
You're too good at this game.
nerf you a little just kidding i think i'm pretty average
i could see cauldron lake i thought i could make out the
spot where the island and the cabin had been there was a
light near it it had to be a boat i thought we were going to
a lookout why are we on the lake i thought we were like
gonna be on a top of a build or like a top of a like a peak
or something i was close now oh i had to get the they're
fast i dreaded what i would find we are close now thank you
ah wake wake wakes up in the lodge i tried to hold on to
alice but her form melted away what i was losing control dr
hartman stood in her place i wanted to hit him but my arms
were jelly he smiled It was a reassuring smile Wake wakes up
Wake wakes up inside She is in the lodge Right now it's very
important that you stay calm We don't want you to have
another episode You're a patient at my clinic Have been for
a while now Oh You're a patient in my clinic You have been
for a while now
Hmm Hmm Hmm Hmm Wait Hey, I'm here!
I'm coming!
Who's in?
No, get away!
I'm sorry, please, it's late!
The boss didn't know who he was messing with!
I didn't know!
I swear, I didn't know!
We don't know who she is!
She's probably grown!
Who just said we had her make a play ball?
You see, you see?
Please!
Please, oh!
I'm sorry!
What's going on down there?
I don't know if he's doing so good, you guys.
Oh.
Hello.
Hey, stupid.
Where's my wife?
That you said you don't have her?
Oh my god, grandma.
Grandma, jump scare.
It looks like a wizard of eyes.
Okay.
Wow, the smolder.
Oh,
someone was grabbing his wife.
Grabbing Alice.
Alan waken the lake.
Dead space?
Well, not dead space.
Uh, Bioshock?
Oh my gosh.
What?
Oh wow, end of episode 3!
Big Daddy, yeah.
Alright, I'm gonna skip it because...
Sorry, I keep getting DMCA'd by this game.
Are you seriously telling me that writer just took out my
deputies?
A thriller I supposedly wrote is coming true.
The genre of the story seems to be shifting.
It's turning into a horror story.
But that was a lie.
We don't have his wife.
We don't know where she is.
Our purported kidnapper was eaten up by the dark presence
before it attacked me.
Episode 4, the truth!
We'll watch this before.
It was just a nightmare.
Alice.
There you go, Alan.
Hartman.
I fell.
I had to give you a set attack.
don't fight it you went through another rough period what
right now it's very important that you stay calm we don't
want you to have another episode you're a patient at my
clinic have been for a while now the shock of your wife's
death triggered a mental illness no you're you lie you're
suffering from various symptoms of undifferentiated
schizophrenia schizophrenia it's okay alan just let go No,
Alice!
No!
Alan, wake in the lodge.
It's been nine years.
I felt groggy.
Whatever Hartman had bumped in me was making me numb.
I felt like this was happening to someone else.
Someone I was watching on television.
I couldn't think.
I couldn't focus.
I become so numb.
there every time so no no no no
it's just me that's like me every more like you oh good
evening no wait wait i'm sorry i want to i'm done with the
game i was
i was having a moment
Well, guys, thank you so much for Alan Wake, episode 3.
That was a trip.
But boy, golly, did that one drag on.
Holy cow.
I felt like it was just one trip in after it was like, one
thing.
It was so long.
I'm just like, where did we?
We started at the trailer park and then the FBI.
And then we were running from literally everything.
But this was a lot of fun.
so thank you guys thank you thank you appreciate this
playthrough though i'm glad i'm having so much fun with it
so thank you guys so much i am uh let's see oh arigato too
wow dargo thank you uh thank you for the stream veto sorry
it looks like i got shadow banned again this room oh no i
was stuck lurking for a while but grand theft allen was
super fun to watch good job beating the evil zombies pipes
of mine carts i'll be over great night thank you so much
thank you um i am going to send you guys over to nimi
nightmare she is streaming uh right now so yeah and she's
got a special announcement i can't wait to hear what it is
so thank you guys thank you thank you thank you i will see
you next.
And, um, yeah.
First thing, let's say thank you so much for the vlog.
Get there.
Thank you.
You might like slash hate the next chapter.
Oh, boy.
That makes it.
I might.
Well, not next week.
Next week.
I am all full.
But how many chapters?
I've asked this every time.
Hold on.
I'm going to look it up myself.
Alan Wake number of episodes.
Oh, six.
Oh, okay.
For some reason, I thought there were eight.
okay perfect maybe so next week will be four maybe five and
six i'll do the week after and it's like the same week you
know we could do like friday saturday and knock them out or
something but yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah six plus two
that's why i kept thinking a yes yes yes um but cool awesome
thank you guys thank you thank you thank you i will see you
later bye bye
I do have some things to do, so, and I was like, oh, man,
I'm going to go eat and then work on my stuff.
So, enjoy your weekend.
Bye-bye.